Another Thing That Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The SCP Foundation: Dr. Bright is
not allowed to apply SCP-963 to any major
political figures.
Again.
So we’ve got some background here.
Anyone who has seen our video on SCP-4444
will know that a species of aliens almost
destroyed our planet in the year 2000 after
they possessed presidential candidate Al Gore.
In order to stop them, Dr. Bright needed to
take over the body of George W. Bush to run
against him.
While this was an emergency where certain
risks needed to be taken, our current geopolitical
landscape is already too wild and too fractious
to risk Dr. Bright ever rising to any kind
of political power.
Though if he did, he would probably run on
the major campaign slogan “C’mon, Guys,
You’ve Had Worse!”